I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to another
edition of ask Evan today maintain a
question from one of our Facebook fans
on the Telus talks business Facebook
page John Carter who wrote insane I have
a question for Evan comic com for the
challenge series for growing real estate
investment business what are the
employee roles we should hire as we grow
we currently have an outsourced model
with marketing web design property
management legal accounting and
bookkeeping outsourced so thanks for the
question John congrats and building the
business up to that size so far I'm
going to give you three pieces advice
that I hope will help you take your
business to the next step number one
what score do your business before you
outsource anything in your business you
should ask yourself which functions are
core to what you do and which are
supportive for example bookkeeping and
accounting makes sense to outsource your
real estate company not an accounting
firm let them do what they do best so
you can do more of what you do best
other areas like marketing can be
trickier is your marketing methodology a
key component to your company is that a
differentiating factor compared your
competition is it core to the way you do
business vital to your success if no
then outsource if yes then keep it
in-house as you building your business
think of it as an asset that you're
eventually going to sell and for a great
price too if your marketing process is
indeed core to your success then keeping
it internally increases the value of
your asset you can't leverage outsourced
bookkeeping for example to sell your
business for a higher price outsourcing
is a fantastic way to let other people
do what score to them and let you do
what score to you before you outsource
your next function think about what
really makes your company successful and
what's going to boost your growth over
the next five years anything that is a
key component to that success should be
made core and kept in-house
number two where do you add the most
value just because a function is core to
your company success it doesn't mean
that you have to do it next up is to
think about what is core to you yes it's
time to give up control it's easy to
give away the tasks you're not good at
and don't enjoy but you'll often have to
give up some projects that you do enjoy
and are the best at because your time
can be put to better use somewhere else
where do you add the most value to your
business the more time you spend on
those high-value activities the more
your business is going to grow the other
tasks still have to get done but they
can be handled by someone on your team
I'm constantly asking myself from the
way to the office what can I do today
that will add the most value to my
business if you find yourself doing too
many repetitive or low value tasks to
think about elimination automation and
delegation number three make room for
CEO time my final piece of advice is to
make sure you spend time on your
business and not just in it this is what
I call CEO time if you're constantly
being dragged back into the day-to-day
operations of your business then you
won't be able to spend any time growing
it when you're first starting out you
have to get past the survival stage
where you have enough money to put food
on the table and pay the bills after
that it's time to think about growth and
it won't come with you trying to do
everything yourself make sure you've
blocked out time every week ideally
every day where people know not to
distract you so you can have your CEO
time to focus on growth projects for
most entrepreneurs is easiest to have
their CEO time in the morning before the
craziness of the day hits as much as
possible I try to build a no crisis
business where we can focus on being
proactive and chasing down new
opportunities instead of constantly
reacting to emergencies and putting out
fires you get there by controlling your
time and setting boundaries around what
you will and will not accept you have to
first appreciate and recognize that your
time is extremely valuable before others
will
thank you for joining me for another
edition of ask Evan if you like the
video you wanted some more please give
it a thumbs up below it makes you want
to do more of these videos for you and
if you have a question about this video
or question about your own business I
feel free to leave in the comments
section below or join us in the facebook
conversation and hopefully we can
feature you in the next challenge series
video that we do for Telus talks
business
you